after a year in a re-education camp he
was allowed out but not into freedom he
showed us the clothes factory built
inside the camp's grounds
was a witness at today's hearing of the
wiga tribunal in central london
it's seeking to answer whether china is
conducting genocide and other crimes
against humanity against minorities in
xinjiang in the northwest of the country
this is a people's tribunal it has no
judicial political or legal power
but it has infuriated china which
strongly denies the allegations saying
its policies in xinjiang are to fight
extremism
it has repeatedly attacked the tribunal
and even applied sanctions to its
chairman
and it's tried to pressure the british
government
this tribunal
and the noise
it is creating
is destructive
in terms of
misleading
certain sectors of the society
that those who escaped xinjiang are
still taking their chance to put their
evidence on public record
arumbic coxabic was detained for having
dual citizenship and held in the same
camp as ibrahim he was singled out for
punishment foreign
in london at least the witnesses can
speak freely
they know that is impossible in xinjiang
where every word is watched
tom cheshire sky news shanghai